à la verrière pas d'union de la gauche
en vue dans ce bastion communiste depuis
les années 1970 onze élus de la majorité
dont quatre adjoints vont mener une
liste face à la maire sortante nelly
duthu bonsoir jean yves les bons soirs
vous êtes le premier adjoint de la
commune de la verrière en charge de
l'éducation et de la petite enfance et
vous serez la tête de liste de cette
candidature divers gauche ensemble la
verrière citoyenne début 2019 on
rappelle le contexte vous aviez créé
votre propre groupe au sein du conseil
municipal pourquoi partir divisés pour
ce scrutin
c'est une question en effet pourquoi
partir divisés alors que tous nous
nous amener à être ensemble
écoutez on a été confronté à des
différences avec madame la maire
qui n'a pas une écoute
comment dire tout à fait
[Musique]
démocratique républicaine dénonce l
époque un manque de concertation c'est
ça on n'est pas du tout dans le dans les
changes le décide
sans concerter et donc à partir de là
malgré nos différentes interventions des
uns et des autres pour le lui dire pour
dira t il faut changer de stratégie être
un peu plus ouverts à l écoute de vos de
vos adjoints elle n'en a pas tenu compte
et donc à partir de là
s'en est suivi toute une série de
décisions de la part des uns et des
autres qui nous ont conduit à constituer
un groupe en effet au sein de la
majorité
qui par le passé il existait aussi
c'était pas une pas une nouveauté en soi
même si la sensibilité au fond est la
même celle celle de gauche c'est une
sensibilité de gauche bien évidemment
oui oui puisque la liste était de gauche
complètement de gauche d'ailleurs pas un
risque du coup de voir la verrière
justement n'être plus une commune de
gauche c'est que c'est paris finalement
de se lancer c'est ce qu'on est visé
c'est ce qu'on nous dit c'est ce qu'on
nous pousse à entendre
après après il ya un moment donné où il
faut prendre ses responsabilités si vous
voulez nous on a considéré qu' au regard
des projets qui étaient posées sur la
table sans concertation et des décisions
qui étaient prises par rapport à ces
projets il fallait bien réagir et agir
ça veut dire aussi agir et donc on a agi
après on est aussi dans une démocratie
et on a aussi le droit
je pense pour l'intérêt des habitants de
dire quand on a des différences et de
pas avoir peur d'aller face aux
électeurs se présenter voilà et des
divergences notamment aux propos d'un
sujet 1 c'était la future crèche qui
doit être construit en lieu et place de
l'ancienne pmi du coup c'est là c'était
là juste conséquence de proposer cette
phase non non c'est pas c'est pas la
crèche où elle même parce que soit la
crèche c'était l'un des sujets en tout
cas de divergence
sur les moyens mais oui mais pas sur
l'emplacement de la crèche et pas sur la
décision de la cre est ce parce que là
l'emplacement de moi je les propose il
ya bien longtemps je pensais que la pmi
et ont été retirés de notre ville à
notre dame de grandes peines si vous
voulez c'est quand même un outil qui
était fort apprécié de la population est
donc
cet outil étant présents étant là il
fallait lui redonner une seconde vie je
pense que la crèche s'y prêtait bien
enfin l'idée de la crèche se prête bien
c'est en effet là divergences ne portent
pas c'était sur les financements non
portent elles portent plutôt sur le
projet d'ensemble sur sur la ville vous
avez on a porté un projet gare bekale
qui a été approuvé en communauté d'agglo
qui a été validé par le préfet et puis
bloquée depuis maintenant trois ans on
devrait normalement sortir de terre 300
logements là c'est ce qui était prévu
dans le programme mais du fait de la
décision de certains ba aujourd'hui il
n'en est rien et puis sortir certains
d'ailleurs c'est même là s'en émeuve
mais bon
juste avant de parler des priorités
parce que j'ai bien compris que la
guerre beckham c'était l'une des
priorités votre liste vous l'annoncer
comme une liste de gauche ouverte ça
veut dire vous vous revendiquez pas
spécialement d'investiture aujourd'hui
non c'est une liste de gauche ouverte et
sans investiture sans appui de partie
c'est pour être c'est à la question mais
c'est ça la réponse est donc en venons
venons en aux priorités donc vous parler
du projet de gare bécane oui ça projet
d'ensemble si vous voulez on a lancé les
bécanes et quand on a lancé les bécanes
on s'est dit aussi il fallait qu'il
fallait réfléchir autrement pour le
reste de la ville et donc on a aussi et
c'est vrai que c'était pas dans le
programme pensé
à revoir le quartier du bois de l'étang
en l'inscrivant dans la rénovation
urbaine c'est aujourd'hui alors ne venez
pas en tout cas retenu dans l'anru ce
quartier du bois des temps vous avez une
vision différente par rapport à la maire
sortante vous souhaitez une démolition
plus puis une reconstruction c'est ça
on souhaiterait amener les jets quartier
qui comprendrait en effet les
démolitions
on l'a écrit au préfet on a été très
clair là dessus on a été très clair en
conseil municipal comme madame l'a fait
la mère a fait voter une motion dans ce
sens là en faisant venir le collectif
d'ailleurs du bois de l'étang là dessus
nous on a été très très très sincère et
on a dit le pourquoi et pour rester
nécessaire par rapport à une simple
réhabilitation
si je puis dire parce qu'il faut
redonner de l'attractivité à la commune
et aussi à ce quartier qui se meurt
parce qu on a une politique de logement
de la part de l'état qui paupérise le
quartier et qui ne le tire pas vers le
haut vous avez vu que le pisa dit dans
les enquêtes sur l'éducation nationale
peas a dit les différences qui s'opèrent
c'est pas tellement le niveau dépenses
des quais
de notre population qui est pas bonne
c'est l'organisation et la se passer de
spécialisation des
secteurs éducatif qui sont à revoir
c'est ça qui est dit et pas tellement le
niveau d'apprentissage de
nos enfants donc à partir de là nous on
considère qu'il faut en effet travaillé
à ça de manière à tirer nos enfants vers
le haut oui parce que aujourd'hui c'est
comme ça que ça marche d'autres sociétés
fonctionnent à dessus et ans l'un des
sujets importants aussi à la verrière où
la population est davantage jeunes c'est
le chômage 16 % de demandeurs d'emploi
dans la commune on est bien au dessus de
la moyenne dans les yvelines ça une
attention particulière aussi vécu alors
d'autres tafer oui parce que ce qui est
terrible c'est qu'on a les outils pour
répondre à ça et qu'on s'en sert pas
bien il ya un potentiel voilà mais à la
verrière et sur le territoire de saint
quentin je rappelle qu ennemi sur lequel
intercommunale quand même donc c'est un
outil en faveur de la jeunesse
dont on se sert pas bien
il ya le pôle emploi il ya des centres
de formation si vous voulez les outils
sur le territoire il existe je veux dire
si c'est de l'art est le lien avec
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines faut il faut travailler là
dessus et et il faut arrêter de penser
que la commune peut à elle seule régler
le problème c'est pas possible il faut
en effet s'appuyer sur les partenaires
qui sont compétents qu'ils savent faire
et puis et puis c'est tout voilà les
autres priorités alors on parle de
plusieurs projets le réaménagement du
carrefour de la manne me donne qui
concerne la commune de la verrière ça
c'est un sujet à suivre aussi c'est le
désenclavement rappelleront il ya eu
deux réunions qui se sont tenues
dont sur lesquels moi j'ai participé sur
lequel j'ai dit un certain nombre de
choses on est ce carrefour va permettre
en effet de désenclaver la ville mais en
même temps si on ne fait rien sur le
passage souterrain
qui ouvre sur la sur la vie je crains
fort que
on soit embêté dans les années qui
viennent donc je propose que là on
regarde d'un peu plus près cette
situation là tout comme on pourrait
regarder une ouverture vers la route de
de coignières allant vers le minime pour
rejoindre le carrefour de là marc
caillaud de la mare c'est pas demain pas
le faire car camions en tout cas ce
c'est le des fontaines par d'autres que
moi j'ai cherché en obtenant de
carrefour une dernière question ce qu'on
arrive à la fin de cet entretien sur la
participation il était aux alentours de
54 % à la verrière en 2014 comment
mobiliser les électeurs on a dans les
voir tout simplement en allant porter le
projet en porte à porte en expliquant en
rassurant en rappelant qu' ils sont
aussi des stickers de leur avenir et que
c'est important pour eux que d'aller
dire dans les urnes ne le choix qu'ils
souhaiteraient voir naître pour les six
ans qui viennent après vos prochains
rendez vous est ce que vous avez des
meetings des réunions on a une réunion
publique demain soir sur le
l'aménagement du territoire et
l'écologie sur la question
environnementale
on en a une autre le 18 décembre la plus
tôt sur le handicap la santé et puis
les anciens
et puis bon moment voilà merci jean yves
blais je rappelle que vous êtes la tête
de liste de donc la liste ensemble la
verrière citoyenne et je précise que
dans la commune la maire sortante nelly
duthu est également candidate tout comme
le conseiller municipal d'opposition de
droite nicola dainville voilà c'est la
fin de ce journal merci de l'avoir suivi
et belle soirée à tous sur tv 78